[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a hacer una pregunta conocéis
esta mujer se llama úrsula von der layen
y os puedo asegurar que hace un mes yo
no tenía ni idea de quién era esta mujer
y como yo el 90% de los europeos pues
bien esta señora alemana está a punto de
convertirse en la presidenta de la
comisión europea la persona más poderosa
de toda la unión europea para que os
hagáis una idea a partir del 1 de
noviembre que es cuando tiene previsto
jurar el cargo von der layen será la
homóloga europea al mismísimo donald
trump
[Música]
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
sobre todo los que hayáis votado en las
elecciones europeas pero esta mujer de
dónde ha salido como sabéis en mayo de
este año 2019
los europeos fuimos a las urnas os
explicamos aquí en visual político en un
vídeo que hicimos con curiosidad que
merece la pena ver aunque sólo sea por
las animaciones tan impresionantes que
tiene pues bien millones de ciudadanos
europeos metimos un papelito a las urnas
para elegir a nuestros representantes en
el parlamento europeo y no el nombre de
ursula von der leyen no estaba en
ninguna de las papeletas
nadie la nombró en ningún debate y por
supuesto no dio ninguna entrevista por
aquellos tiempos esta mujer solo era la
ministra de defensa de alemania los
alemanes la conocería mucho pero para el
resto de los europeos era completamente
irrelevante y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos a ver fonseca en las
elecciones europeas no se vota al
presidente de la comisión y tenéis razón
en las elecciones votamos al parlamento
es decir al poder legislativo después el
legislativo junto con el consejo europeo
son quienes eligen al ejecutivo todo eso
es cierto es decir que aunque von der
leyen no se presentará a las elecciones
es perfectamente legal que la nombren
presidenta
[Música]
ahora bien políticamente es un
movimiento un poquito difícil de
entender por poner un ejemplo sería como
si el parlamento español en lugar de
elegir a uno de los candidatos a las
elecciones terminará eligiendo al
consejero de salud de andalucía como
presidente del gobierno a ver que sí que
legalmente sería posible pero
políticamente sería un escándalo en toda
regla y si es cierto el nombramiento de
von der layen es un hecho histórico será
la primera mujer que gobierne europa tal
vez en un futuro recordaremos su nombre
junto al de margaret thatcher o angela
merkel probablemente sea una gran
presidenta pero la pregunta que hoy nos
hacemos es hasta qué punto puede decirse
que la unión europea es democrática y
ursula von der layen ha sido elegida sin
siquiera presentarse a las elecciones
cuál es el papel del presidente de la
comisión europea es más que podemos
esperar de la comisión von der layen hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
la burbuja brush elite en el año 1992 se
firmó el acuerdo de maastricht podríamos
decir que este fue el momento en el que
nació la unión europea con capital en
bruselas bélgica hasta ese momento la
comunidad económica europea era
solamente eso una comunidad económica un
macroacuerdo de libre comercio pero que
apenas tenía implicaciones políticas
pues bien en 1992 nació la unión europea
que es algo así como un gobierno que
engloba a todos los países miembros
después aparecería el euro el tratado de
ámsterdam el tratado de niza y el de
lisboa
todos ellos documentos muy complicados
que nunca se han terminado de explicar
muy bien
a día de hoy prácticamente nadie
entiende cómo funciona la unión europea
y seamos honestos los medios de
comunicación tampoco ayudan precisamente
habréis oído mil veces repetir que
bruselas dice esto bruselas dice lo otro
pero lo cierto es que bruselas es decir
las instituciones europeas son tres
cuerpos muy importantes y cada uno actúa
de formas muy distintas vamos a
explicarlo con un ejemplo que conocéis
todos el dichoso artículo 13 para quien
no lo sepa cuando digo artículo 13 me
refiero a la directiva europea que
regula el copyright para los youtubers
que hemos hablado hasta la saciedad de
ello es más visual polític tenemos este
vídeo donde os lo explicábamos pero hoy
no vamos a centrarnos en lo que dice la
ley sino en cómo funciona el proceso
legislativo para sacarla pues bien todo
empieza con el consejo europeo
[Música]
y aquí es donde están representados
todos los países miembros y sus
respectivos gobiernos y dicen
necesitamos una ley para regular el
copyright en internet escribir unas
líneas generales en un documento y se lo
mandan atentos a la comisión europea
[Música]
la comisión europea sería lo más
parecido al brazo ejecutivo en europa lo
más parecido al gobierno de un país como
puede ser españa o colombia y tienen
unos comisarios que serían el
equivalente a los ministros o los
secretarios de estado en eeuu en la
comisión europea se lee en este
documento con esas líneas maestras y
sacan una propuesta legislativa es decir
algo así como un borrador de la ley y
después cuando han terminado de
escribirlo se lo mandan al parlamento
europeo
[Música]
y
el parlamento europeo que también lo
podemos llamar la eurocámara funciona es
como cualquier otro parlamento del mundo
ahora bien tiene una característica
única no tienen iniciativa legislativa
es decir que no pueden proponer una ley
solo pueden discutir lo que les llega de
la comisión europea así que los
diputados discuten crean sus grupos de
estudio y finalmente sacan una versión
nueva de la ley pero si recordáis el
vídeo que hicimos sobre el artículo 13
el [ __ ] está en los detalles es decir
que siempre hay muchos aspectos muy
concretos que tenemos que pulir y aquí
es cuando llegamos a la siguiente fase
la de los triálogos
[Música]
los diálogos son un proceso en el que se
juntan los representantes del parlamento
y los representantes de la comisión y
los representantes del consejo y ahí es
donde discuten los últimos detalles de
la ley finalmente después de meses y
meses de negociación sale una ley
definitiva que se vuelve a votar en el
parlamento pero en este caso y atentos
no se pueden discutir detalles los
diputados solamente pueden votar sí o no
[Música]
fijados en una cosa según este sistema
la comisión europea tiene muchísimo
poder son básicamente los únicos que
pueden proponer legislación en el
parlamento por ejemplo en un país como
españa el gobierno suele proponer leyes
pero también el propio parlamento puede
sacar sus propias propuestas en eeuu por
ejemplo el famoso green new deal que ha
propuesto casi cortes surgió
efectivamente de ocasión cortes que es
una congresista no está en la casa
blanca sin embargo en este caso todo el
poder para proponer leyes está en la
comisión y en el consejo y este detalle
es muy importante el consejo europeo
está compuesto por los gobiernos
elegidos por los votantes de cada país
es decir que de algún modo tiene
legitimidad democrática lo mismo ocurre
con el parlamento se elige en las
elecciones así que es totalmente
democrático pero quien elige el
presidente o presidenta de la comisión y
aquí es donde llegamos al gran debate
hace 5 años algunos políticos
propusieron el sistema de expansión
candidateó básicamente cada partido
político elegiría a su candidato para
presidente es decir que aunque tú votes
a una lista de eurodiputados también
sabrías a quién vas a votar como posible
presidente de la comisión en cierto modo
sería un sistema parecido al de españa
por ejemplo en españa no votamos al
presidente del gobierno cuando votamos
en unas elecciones generales pero todos
sabemos que cuando votamos por ejemplo a
la lista de diputados del partido
socialista estos van intentar hacer que
pedro sánchez sea el presidente el
problema pues que en europa muchos
partidos políticos y sobre todo muchos
países miembros no están para nada de
acuerdo con este speed el candidato
[Música]
pensadlo bien como decíamos antes ahora
mismo el consejo europeo compuesto por
todos los gobiernos de todos los países
miembros puede elegir a quien le dé la
gana como presidente sin embargo con
este sistema de spitz en candidato solo
podrían elegir dentro de una lista muy
pequeña propuesta por los partidos del
parlamento así que mientras se debatía
durante unos años estuvo el pitcnt
candidato en system se convirtió
simplemente en una especie de acuerdo de
caballeros y eso es exactamente lo que
ocurrió en las elecciones de 2014 en
este caso los dos partidos más votados
los socialdemócratas y los populares
formaron un gobierno de coalición
[Música]
el speed en candidata en del partido
popular europeo era jean claude juncker
del que hemos hablado hasta la saciedad
aquí en visual político y como los
populares eran la primera fuerza juncker
pasó a ser el presidente de la comisión
apoyado por los socialdemócratas y os
preguntaréis qué ha pasado en estas
elecciones de 2019 pues básicamente lo
que pasa tantas veces con los pactos de
caballeros y las normas no escritas que
llega a alguien que no quiere cumplirlos
en este caso los populares y los
socialdemócratas no suman la mayoría
absoluta necesitan el apoyo de los
liberales y los liberales no quieren a
ninguno de los speed en candidatos que
habían propuesto los grandes partidos y
os preguntaréis cómo han terminado
eligiendo a la ministra de defensa de
alemania que se les ha pasado por la
cabeza
la respuesta es una lucha de poder ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
fitch en candy tan no méxico hay cinco
top jobs en la unión europea son los
cinco cargos que más poder tienen en
toda europa y esos cargos son presidente
de la comisión vicepresidente de la
comisión que es el que se encarga de la
política exterior presidente del
parlamento europeo presidente del
consejo europeo y finalmente el
presidente del banco central europeo y
os preguntaréis quién elige a estos
cinco top shops pues veréis según el
famoso tratado de lisboa famoso para
quien lo conozca lo tiene que hacer el
consejo europeo es decir el órgano donde
están los presidentes de todos los
países miembros después necesitan que el
parlamento europeo lo apruebe en
principio parecería razonable que el
presidente fuera el speed en candidato
del partido más votado y diréis quién
estaba a favor de este sistema pues por
supuesto los dos grandes partidos del
parlamento y quién estaba en contra pues
creo que ya os lo podéis imaginar
[Música]
el partido de macrón rechazó el proceso
de speed en cándida pensando bien el
partido de macrón los liberales es la
tercera fuerza más votada en europa es
decir que no son precisamente los que
cortan el bacalao en esta película sin
embargo macrón como presidente de
francia tiene muchísimo poder en el
consejo a fin de cuentas francia es la
segunda economía de la zona euro y
además no olvidéis que el famoso eje
franco-alemán es decir francia y
alemania- suelen votar juntos en todas
las historias y todos los debates del
consejo europeo recordad que tanto
alemania como francia ahora mismo sobre
todo después del brasil son los países
más importantes de europa así que
básicamente macrón dijo yo no quiero
ningún speech en candidato y merkel que
es bastante conciliadora le dijo bueno
pues vale me parece muy bien pones a
quien quieras ahora bien
que sea alemán y así es como salió el
nombre de ursula von der layen era la
mujer perfecta ha pensado bien alemana
pero nacida y criada en bélgica habla
cinco idiomas y por lo que se dice en
los mentideros de bruselas tiene amigos
hasta en el infierno básicamente von der
leyen debe ser la clásica persona que te
encuentras en una fiesta y que cae bien
a todo el mundo vamos que el resto de
países miembros enseguida se hicieron
amigo suyo y básicamente tampoco tenían
mucha posibilidad de elegir así que
dijeron lo que digáis merkel y macrón
oye que es majísima oye esta mujer von
der layen nos ha caído fenomenal
[Música]
y ya sé lo que me vais a decir muchos
venga ya fonseca no me creo que una
decisión tan importante se tome así a la
ligera pues mis queridos amigos de
visual política la política es así
veréis cuando hacemos análisis políticos
aquí en este canal muchas veces
intentamos centrarnos en datos
económicos estrategias electorales
encuestas datos pero muchas veces se nos
olvida que quienes toman las decisiones
son gente de carne y hueso como vosotros
y como yo y muchas veces algo tan tonto
como contar un chiste a tiempo en una
fiesta puede ser crucial para caerle
bien a quien tienes que caerle bien en
europa este tipo de maniobras tienen un
nombre lo llaman la burbuja brush elisa
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque la jugada
de macrón va mucho más allá después de
nombrar a la presidenta de la comisión
macro se acercó a merkel y le dijo vamos
a ver
angela mira hemos puesto una alemana de
tu cuerda por aquí muy bien fenomenal
pero te es para el banco central
europeo- ponemos una francesa y para eso
quién mejor quién tiene mejor currículum
que christine lagard que ha sido
presidenta del fondo monetario
internacional pues dicho y hecho y
pensadlo bien con esto macrón ha matado
dos pájaros de un tiro por un lado
coloca una francesa y por el otro se
quita de medio a una potencial rival en
las próximas elecciones francesas
christina lagarde la presidenta soñada
de los franceses pero esperad un momento
porque si recordáis uso la von der layen
tenía que lograr el visto bueno de la
eurocámara y aunque haya sido por nueve
votos lo ha conseguido y diréis como
como ha conseguido convencer a los
eurodiputados de que la vote en pues
atentos
[Música]
la comisión fondo client según varias
encuestas el principal motivo por el que
los británicos votaron el break sheet
era la falta de control ciudadano sobre
los asuntos europeos en otras palabras
falta de democracia y de transparencia y
claro creo que después de todo lo que os
hemos contado me reconoceréis que algo
de razón no les falta sobre todo cuando
leemos titulares como este lo que vais a
ver a continuación son declaraciones del
que fue el speed en candidata en del
partido popular europeo
manfred weber
webber insta los europarlamentarios a
rechazar las decisiones tomadas en la
trastienda de la diplomacia y ahora
atentos a lo que ha dicho justo un mes
después
y alemán weber insta a los
europarlamentarios a respaldar a font
der layen en la votación para sub top de
la noche a la mañana este señor ha
cambiado de opinión no ha hecho falta
ningún debate público ni nada que
hayamos podido ver los votantes ha
bastado con una negociación de despacho
es decir que nada de democracia y mucho
de conversaciones privadas de nuevo lo
que os decía esto es la burbuja bruce
elite y os preguntaréis qué va a pasar
ahora que podemos esperar que haga la
señora von der layen cuando llega a su
despacho pues lo primero que tiene que
hacer es nombrar a los comisarios que
como os decía antes son el equivalente a
los ministros según la legislación
europea estos comisarios tienen que ser
28 uno por cada país miembro es decir
que por ejemplo no puede haber dos
alemanes ni dos franceses ni dos
eslovenos
[Música]
ahora bien no es lo mismo ser el
comisario de hacienda y finanzas por
ejemplo que el de ayuda humanitaria y
cooperación al desarrollo que con todos
mis respectos tiene bastante menos
presupuesto y menos influencia en la
política de momento ha anunciado que
tendrá un colegio con paridad de
comisarios entre hombres y mujeres cada
país tiene un comisario y amon der layen
le corresponde asignarle las funciones
que considere oportunas pero esperado un
momento porque no todo es tan sencillo
la señora von der leyen no tiene tanta
capacidad de maniobra como pensamos
después de elegir a los comisarios tiene
que ir al parlamento europeo y porque
los exámenes del parlamento europeo los
comisarios no son un trámite en estas
audiencias suelen caer un par de
candidatos por ejemplo en 2014
la candidata eslovena no pasó los
exámenes y hubo que buscar a otra es
decir que font der layen puede tener
algún que otro dolor de cabeza a la hora
de formar gobierno
es decir que en este caso sí que
podríamos estar hablando de un auténtico
contrapoder para el ejecutivo pero ahora
la pregunta es para vosotros creéis que
macrón ha hecho bien en liquidar el
sistema de speed en candidato tienen
razón los euroescépticos cuando hablan
de falta de democracia en europa podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros a visual
política y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones y estar al día de lo que
ocurre tanto en la unión europea como en
todo el planeta tierra si os ha gustado
este vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en
el próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]